.
* Rockige Gitarrenmusik *
Fast jeder zweite, junge Mensch
in der Schweiz ist tätowiert.
Tattoos haben den Sprung
aus der Schmuddelecke
in den Mainstream längst geschafft.
Ob Influencer, Musiker,
Sportlerinnen - mit einem Tattoo
unterstreichen sie ihre
Persönlichkeit und Individualität.
Die wenigsten denken dabei
an gesundheitliche Risiken.
Und manche können
nicht genug davon kriegen.
Soll ich's mal zeigen?
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Gemächliche Musik *
Dominik Dietrich macht sich bereit,
um heute ein weiteres Tattoo
auf seinen Körper stechen zu lassen.
Ein Gesamtkunstwerk, in das er bisher
mehr als 200 schmerzvolle Stunden
und über 130'000 Fr. investiert hat.
Und es ist noch lange nicht fertig.
Gehst du heute zu Fabe?
- Ja, jetzt dann gleich.
Was ist an der Reihe?
- Heute ist diese Seite dran.
Okay, den Ghostbuster?
- Ja, ich hoffe es, ja.
Als ich ihn kennenlernte,
hatte er noch nicht so viele.
Er hatte
diesen schrecklichen Vogel hier
und diesen Arm.
Und das war's dann auch.
Am Anfang fand ich es speziell,
aber das Schöne an ihm ist,
dass er so ist, wie er ist,
dass er dazu steht
und es ihm gefällt.
Die Art und Weise der Tattoos
ist nicht meine grosse Leidenschaft.
Am schönsten finde ich den Tiger,
denn er stach ihn,
als Niklas zur Welt kam.
Sein Geburtsdatum ist auch da.
Ich finde es sehr schön, dass das
ein wichtiger Teil von ihm ist
und zu seinem Körper gehört.
Tiger.
Schau mal, hier auf dem Rücken ist
dein anderes Lieblingsbild, oder?
Die findest du auch toll, oder?
Bugs Bunny.
- Bugs Bunny?
Nein, das ist ein anderer.
Haben wir Bugs Bunny?
Nein, ich glaube,
Bugs Bunny haben wir nicht.
Doch er hat recht.
Aber diese kennst du?
Scooby-Doo.
- Scooby-Doo!
Den hast du dir sogar gewünscht.
Dominik arbeitet
bei der Gewerkschaft syndicom
und seinen bunten Körper sieht er
auch als politisches Statement.
Als ich noch in St. Gallen wohnte,
war ich politisch sehr aktiv.
Ich durfte auch für den Nationalrat
kandidieren, das war 2015.
Ich wollte mein Aussehen nutzen,
um darauf aufmerksam zu machen,
dass wir alle gleich sind, egal, ob
wir schwarz, weiss oder bunt sind.
Deshalb müssen auch alle die glei-
chen Rechte haben auf dieser Welt.
Es war keine einfache Zeit.
Durch mein Auftreten erlitt ich
Shitstorms und erhielt Drohungen.
Aber ich bin überzeugt,
dass ich viele Menschen ansprechen
und zum Nachdenken bringen konnte.
Schlussendlich ist es das,
was zählt:
dass sich die Leute Gedanken
machen zu den Themen.
Deshalb machte ich das auch gerne.
Und noch eine Leidenschaft
verdient ein Tattoo:
Ich war schon immer ein Fan
von "Knight Rider", "Baywatch"
und dementsprechend
auch von David Hasselhoff.
Einmal wollten wir mit drei Kollegen
nach Prag in die Ferien fahren.
Am Abend davor
boten sie mir die Wette an,
dass sie mir die Ferien bezahlten,
wenn ich mir ein Porträt von David
Hasselhoff tätowieren würde.
Ich stimmte natürlich sofort zu
und liess mir das Tattoo stechen -
an einer
etwas unvorteilhaften Stelle.
Einige Jahre später
hatte ich die Chance,
David Hasselhoff
persönlich kennenzulernen.
Ich war im Dilemma, dass ich ihm
nicht gleich beim ersten Treffen
diese unvorteilhafte Stelle
zeigen konnte.
Das wäre ein wenig speziell gewesen.
Deshalb liess ich mir
auf die Schnelle
noch ein Bild von David Hasselhoff
tätowieren.
Das Treffen fand tatsächlich statt,
und David Hasselhoff flippte aus
vor Freude, als er das Tattoo sah.
Er hat
auf meiner Haut unterschrieben,
und einen Tag später
liess ich es auch nachstechen.
Die Entdeckung Polynesiens durch
den Seefahrer James Cook im 18. Jh.
und die Verschleppung
von edlen Wilden,
die mit merkwürdigen Zeichen
und Bildern bemalt waren,
stiessen in Europa
auf ein staunendes Publikum.
Tatau nannten die Polynesier
ihre Körperkunst
und aus Tatau entwickelte sich später
das Wort Tattoo.
Die Zeichen,
welche eine tiefe Symbolik haben,
wurden in Polynesien,
oder wie hier in Sumatra,
mit einem einfachen Holzstück
und einem spitz gefeilten Knochen
tätowiert.
Sie zeigen die Stammeszugehörigkeit
und dienen als Schutz vor Krankheiten
oder bösen Geistern.
Die Kraft und Symbolik, die
von traditionellen Tattoos ausgehen,
faszinieren auch Andi Stiegler.
Vor einiger Zeit
liess er sich bereits
ein samoanisches Stammes-Tattoo
auf Arm und Schulter stechen -
allerdings mit der Tätowiermaschine.
Nun spielt er mit dem Gedanken,
sich ein Tattoo auf traditionelle
samoanische Art klopfen zu lassen.
Dass es ein schmerzhaftes Unterfangen
ist, weiss er,
dennoch ist er fest entschlossen,
es zu wagen.
Wenn du etwas
in dieser Art möchtest ...
Ein samoanischer Tätowierer
ist nicht gleich um die Ecke.
Wenn du Glück hast,
ist mal einer als Gasttätowierer
an einer Convention
oder in irgendeiner Ortschaft.
Für das Projekt,
das ich im Kopf hatte,
reichte das einfach nicht.
Schlussendlich
stiess ich auf einen aus Freiburg.
Als ich das erste Bild von ihm sah,
dachte ich:
"Was für ein Freak,
das wird nie etwas."
Dann schaute ich mir seine Homepage
an, las über sein Leben,
machte mich schlau im Netz
und merkte,
dass er sehr kreativ ist und jemand,
der nicht gefällig ist,
sondern das macht, was er sieht,
nicht das,
was man ihm aufzwingen will.
Das, was er sieht,
sieht er auf deinem Körper.
Er macht ausschliesslich
samoanische Tätowierungen
nach traditioneller Art.
Wenn du ein Segelschiff
mit geraden Linien willst,
bist du bei ihm fehl am Platz -
das geht nicht.
Im Tattoostudio in Freiburg im Breis-
gau erwartet ihn Tomasi Sulu'Ape.
Erst im persönlichen Gespräch
entstehen die Muster für das Tatau.
Interessant, etwas so zu machen.
Und die Bedeutung?
Warum möchtest du es?
Beim Kanufahren
hatte ich Zeit zu überlegen -
auf dem Wasser, der Rhythmus ...
Da dachte ich,
ein Tattoo auf dem Bein wäre gut.
Etwa von hier bis hier unten.
- Ja, ungefähr.
Einfach nicht bis hier runter.
- Das legen wir gar nicht fest.
Wir machen das einfach
im jetzigen Zustand,
setzen ein paar Grundlinien
und dann beginnen wir.
Sehr gut, klingt interessant.
- Super. - Ich freue mich.
Let's go.
- Go.
* Ruhige Perkussion *
Bis das Grundkonzept steht,
ist immer wichtig,
dass der Flow
und die Energie stimmen
des ganzen Gerüsts.
Wir können gleich loslegen.
Ah, ja. Genau so etwas
habe ich mir vorgestellt.
Das kann ich noch nicht zuordnen,
aber ich vertraue dir.
Und bringst du all meine Wünsche
auf diese kleine Fläche? - Ja.
Ja, ich wäre so weit.
Du auch?
- Ich werde nie so weit sein.
* Ruhige Perkussion *
Seinen deutschen Namen hat Tomasi
vor langer Zeit abgelegt.
Damals, als er auf einer Weltreise
in Samoa hängen blieb
und seine Leidenschaft für
traditionelle Tataus entdeckte.
Er lernte die Familie Sulu'ape
kennen.
Viele Meister
der samoanischen Tätowierkunst
stammen aus dieser Familie.
Wie ein Sohn wurde er
von der Gemeinschaft aufgenommen
und in die Geheimnisse
des Handwerks eingeführt.
Dieses Wissen über
die rituellen Regeln, die Technik,
aber v.a. über die spirituelle
Bedeutung der Symbole,
wird von Generation
zu Generation weitergegeben.
Denn Tataus sind für Samoaner
weit mehr als blosser Körperschmuck.
Die Tätowierungen
zeigen Status und Herkunft,
sie sollen Kraft spenden
und sogar die Lebensgeschichte
des Trägers beeinflussen können.
Auch die Herstellung
der traditionellen Werkzeuge
muss ein Tätowierer beherrschen.
* Asiatisch anmutende Klänge *
Ich darf ja eigentlich
nicht lustig sein.
Ich müsste so da sitzen auf dem
grossen, schwarzen Kung-Fu-Rug
und ein total strenges Gesicht
machen.
Das bin aber nicht ich,
ich bin eher der Lustige.
Ich versuche so,
die Leute abzuholen.
Da reisse ich halt ab und zu
ein paar Witze.
Es fällt dann dem Kunden einfacher.
Wir haben hier keine Samoaner,
die uns mit der Ukulele
eine Show bieten beim Tätowieren.
Das wäre schön,
aber haben wir nicht.
Die ältesten Tattoos, die
an einem Menschen entdeckt wurden,
sind etwa 5'400 Jahre alt.
Rund 60 Tätowierungen
zieren den Körper von Ötzi.
Seine Tattoos wurden nicht gestochen,
sondern in die Haut geritzt.
Da sich die Zeichen
auf Akkupunkturstellen befinden,
vermuten Wissenschaftler,
dass sie aus medizinischen Gründen
zur Schmerzlinderung
angebracht wurden.
Man geht davon aus, dass sich
die Methoden des Tätowierens
bei verschiedenen Völkern der Erde
selbstständig und unabhängig
voneinander entwickelt haben.
Im Mittelalter verbreiteten sich in
Europa christlich-religiöse Motive.
Bis 1890 wurden in Bosnien
katholische Mädchen tätowiert,
um einen Übertritt zum Islam
zu verhindern.
Später waren es v.a. Matrosen,
Kriminelle oder Rocker,
die ihre Gesinnung oder Zugehörigkeit
unter die Haut stechen liessen.
Entsprechend anrüchig
war der Ruf von Tätowierten.
Diese Vorurteile spürte auch Dischy,
als er 1974
das erste Tattoostudio der Schweiz
in Rheineck
im Kanton St. Gallen eröffnete.
Das Schweizer Fernsehen berichtete
ein paar Jahre später darüber.
Die Meinung schien allerdings
bereits gemacht zu sein.
(Originalton) Laut einer Studie sind
Tätowierfreudige meistens Männer
aus beruflich
und sozial schwachen Verhältnissen.
Er unterscheidet zwischen
zwei verschiedenen Tattooträgern:
Der eine hat exhibitionistische Züge
und steht auf seine Hautbilder.
Der andere braucht sie,
um den starken Mann zu markieren.
* Gemütliches Soul-Lied *
Wir fragten Mitglieder des Tattoo-
klubs Rheineck nach ihren Motiven.
Für mich ist es ein Hobby, wie für
jemanden, der Briefmarken sammelt.
Mir gefallen die Bilder
und alles Drum und Dran.
Ich finde es schön,
wenn jemand tätowiert ist.
Mir gefällt es einfach sehr gut.
Ja, ich habe auch Spass
am Tätowieren.
So sieht nicht jeder gleich aus.
Die einen tragen Schmuck,
ich Tattoos.
Mein Mann und ich
leben fürs Tätowieren.
Es ist mal was anders,
wenn man tätowiert ist.
Ich finde es schön.
* Rhythmische Bassmelodie *
Eine Legende war Herbert Hoffmann,
der älteste, aktive Tätowierer
Europas.
Ich sage immer: "Wenn ich mich aus-
ziehe, bin ich noch angezogen."
So ganz nackt fühle ich mich nie.
Angefangen hat er in einem Studio
auf der Reeperbahn in Hamburg.
Die letzten 20 Jahre lebte und
tätowierte er in Heiden im Appenzell.
Meine erste Tätowierung
wurde noch mit Handnadeln gestochen.
Weil es damals noch keine Farben
gab, war alles in Schwarz gemalt.
So habe ich es mir
dann auch sofort machen lassen,
als ich aus der sowjetischen
Kriegsgefangenschaft zurück war.
Im Sitzen ist es doch gemütlicher
als im Stehen, nicht?
Über 50'000 Motive
hat er in seinen 90 Jahren gestochen.
Noch im hohen Alter besuchen ihn
Fans aus der ganzen Welt.
Als ich damals angefangen habe,
und das Tätowieren noch im Argen lag
und geächtet war,
habe ich mir immer gesagt:
"Du musst etwas dafür tun,
dass die Tätowierung
wieder gesellschaftsfähig wird."
Diese Saat ist aufgegangen, und ich
habe sogar sehr grosse Freude daran,
dass ich bestätigt finde, wofür
ich mich damals eingesetzt habe.
Die 1980er-Jahre
lösten einen wahren Tattoo-Boom aus.
Aus dem Gangster-Image
wurde ein Modetrend,
an dem auch immer mehr Frauen
Gefallen fanden.
Sowohl Professionelle wie auch Hobby-
Tätowierer überschwemmten den Markt.
Geräte für den Heimgebrauch
konnten einfacher erworben werden.
Gefährliche Pigmentfarben oder
Hygienevorschriften waren kein Thema.
Heute versuchen über 700
meist kleinere Studios
von der Tätowierkunst zu leben.
Die grösste Konkurrenz
kommt dabei aus Zürich.
Geschäftsführerin Giada Ilardo
hat vor 20 Jahren ebenfalls
mit einem kleinen Studio
in Zürich angefangen,
doch heute besitzt
und führt die zweifache Mutter
das grösste Tattoo-
und Piercingimperium der Schweiz.
Fürs Tätowieren
bleibt ihr keine Zeit mehr.
Denn mittlerweile
arbeiten über 50 Angestellte für sie.
Alles begann, als ich mit 16
zu Hause bei meiner Mutter
in meinem Kinderzimmer begann,
Kunden zu piercen,
also Freunde, deren Freunde,
die dann Kunden wurden.
Ende 16 eröffnete ich
mein erstes Geschäft in Altstetten
und bot dort auch Tätowierungen an.
So nahm das seinen Lauf.
Zwei Jahre später
eröffnete ich das zweite Geschäft.
Die Vision war von Beginn an,
das Ganze
aus der schmuddeligen Ecke zu holen,
denn das hat mich wirklich gestört.
Ich fand die Kunstform toll
und sah grosses Potenzial darin,
aber es wurde vielleicht
einfach falsch vermarktet
oder kam aus der falschen Ecke.
Mir gefiel die Idee, dass alle ein
Tattoo oder Piercing tragen können,
das schön aussehen soll.
Das war der ursprüngliche Gedanke.
Und diesen Gedanken
hat sie mitten in der Stadt Zürich
an bester Lage umgesetzt.
Mit erst 27 Jahren eröffnete sie 2012
ein Tattoo- und Piercinggeschäft
auf drei Etagen an der Löwenstrasse.
Ein hipper Event und Sinnbild
für den Wandel in der Tattooszene.
Mütter, Kinder,
Anwälte, Bauarbeiter -
alle sind bei uns willkommen, alle.
Plötzlich wurden Tattoos
zum boomenden Millionenbusiness.
Mein grösster Traum war immer,
an der Bahnhofstrasse
ein Geschäft zu haben.
Das erschien mir
als 16-Jährige unmöglich.
Für mich war die Bahnhofstrasse
das Nonplusultra, aber unerreichbar.
Das Ziel und die Vision
waren trotzdem da.
Bis heute arbeite ich dafür,
und mein Traum
ist in Erfüllung gegangen.
Ich bin überzeugt, dass man sich
auf etwas spezialisieren soll.
In der Spezialisierung
liegt der Erfolg.
Mir war wichtig,
dass wir die Besten werden
in einem bestimmten Stil,
nämlich Fineline und Micro Realism -
darin sind wir spezialisiert.
In der Schweiz gibt es keine
offizielle Tätowiererausbildung.
Das Wissen wird
innerhalb der Branche weitergegeben.
Bei Giahi kümmert sich Semir
um die Aus- und Weiterbildung
der New Talents.
Um auf dem heutigen Level
wirklich ein professioneller
Tattoo-Artist zu werden,
muss man den Weg
über ein Studio gehen,
wo man professionell lernt
und begleitet wird.
Alles andere, z.B. von zu Hause aus,
wird schwierig sein
und man würde Bildungslücken haben.
Vielleicht wird oft
nur aufs Endergebnis gesetzt,
aber der ganze Prozess und die
Hygiene werden vernachlässigt.
Deshalb sollte man sich heute
in professionelle Hände begeben
in einem Tattostudio.
Um Profi zu sein ...
Ich glaube,
die Entwicklung hört nie auf.
Unsere Branche
entwickelt sich ständig weiter,
es gibt ständig
neue Techniken und Materialien
auf einem noch höheren Niveau.
Deshalb muss man immer am Ball
bleiben, man hat nie ausgelernt.
Um sich das Grundwissen anzueignen,
braucht man ein bis drei Jahre,
bis man auf einem guten Level ist.
Und nebst dem Wissen braucht es
v.a. auch künstlerisches Talent.
Ich finde es super und du, Mami?
Ich sehe natürlich
etwas anderes darin als du.
Oben sind die drei Geschwister
und unten die anderen Blätter. - Ja.
Sie steht für unsere Geschichte,
für meine Mutter und mich.
Meine Mutter
hatte vor einigen Jahren Krebs.
Für jede Chemotherapie
erhielt sie von mir eine Rose.
Am Schluss, als sie krebsfrei war,
erhielt sie noch einmal
gleich viele Rosen.
D.h., sie erhielt
einen Riesenstrauss.
Drei Jahre später wurde bei mir
selbst Krebs diagnostiziert.
Und meine Mutter machte dasselbe,
aber auf ihre Art.
Wir suchten jedes Mal
zusammen eine Rose aus.
Dieses Tattoo
hat eine Bedeutung für mich,
weil es für unsere Geschichte steht,
genau.
Eine Geschichte,
die nun auch unter die Haut geht.
* Surren der Tätowiermaschine *
Die Zeiten,
die wir zusammen erlebt haben,
waren geprägt
von Hoffnung und Angst.
Jetzt haben wir das abgeschlossen.
Sie war mein grösster Halt. Ich
hätte keine Chance gehabt ohne sie.
Ich habe viele Stunden
so an Nadjas Bett verbracht.
Jetzt wiederholt sich das,
aber im Guten.
Das darf man ruhig sagen: im Guten.
Wir dürfen zusammen hier sitzen und
ein Zeichen der Dankbarkeit setzen.
(Tätowierer) Okay.
Ich habe es mir überlegt: Ich möchte
mir die gleiche Rose tätowieren.
Super, dann legen wir los
mit Teil 2.
Machst du es wirklich?
- Ja, sicher.
* Beruhigende Gitarrenklänge *
Es ist mega, Mama.
Es ist sehr emotional.
Das verbindet uns jetzt
nur noch mehr, sagen wir so.
Es ist ein guter Abschluss
für alles
und ein Neustart.
* Heitere Triangelklänge *
Sali, Fabe. - Hoi, geht es gut?
- Tipptopp und selber? - Passt.
Ich habe etwas vorbereitet für dich.
- Zeig mal.
Das ist die Skizze
und das die Reinzeichnung. - Krass.
Ich habe mit den Figuren, die
du mir gegeben hattest, gespielt,
aber entschied mich dann für
die Gummibärenbande und die Busters.
Das ist megageil.
Farblich würde ich es gleich machen
wie auf der anderen Seite.
Auf dem Ausdruck sieht es etwas blau
aus, aber es wird wieder türkis.
Das ist super, perfekt.
Dann lasse ich das raus.
- Ja, das ist gut.
Vielen Dank, megageil.
- Merci.
Das hier ist das Originalfoto
meines Klienten.
Ich zeichnete direkt rein,
um einen Grundaufbau zu machen,
damit ich mir vorstellen kann,
wo die anatomischen Linien sind,
wo kein Motiv sein sollte,
auch damit ich bestehende Motive
gut integrieren
und rundherum bauen kann.
Ich nehme diese Folie ...
... und schicke
sie durch den Thermokopierer.
Ich bin spezialisiert
auf Comic-Tätowierungen, New School,
bunt, farbig -
mache aber auch andere Dinge.
Das Feld ist offen bei mir.
Aber farbig, bunt und Comic -
das ist mein Steckenpferd.
Dieses Steckenpferd ist in Gefahr,
denn die EU
verbietet seit dem 1. Januar 2022
die meisten Tattoofarben.
Vor 20 Jahren
kamen Pigmentfarben in Verruf,
da oft sogenannte Azo-Farben
verwendet wurden,
die auch im Autolack enthalten sind.
Sie sollen krebserregend sein.
Langzeitstudien gibt es noch nicht,
aber die Schweiz
könnte schon bald ein ähnliches
Verbot wie die EU aussprechen.
Wenn das nicht mehr erlaubt ist,
haben wir ein grosses Problem.
Entweder rutschen wir
in die Illegalität ab,
d.h., wir tätowieren weiterhin
mit Farben,
die wir auf Um- oder Abwegen
organisieren,
oder wir tätowieren
nur noch schwarz-weiss.
Aber auch die weisse Farbe
stand schon in der Kritik
und könnte irgendwann
verboten werden, wer weiss.
Wir sind der Spielball
der Gesetzgeber momentan.
So, einmal putzen und rasieren.
Du kannst dein Shirt
auf den Stuhl legen.
Man sieht noch das Tattoo
vom letzten Mal.
Zuerst müssen die Haare weg,
diese tragen immer Bakterien.
Alter, das ist cool.
Dieser Schritt kann 2-3 Std. dauern,
bis für mich alles gut ist.
Ich hatte gehofft,
hier mehr Platz zu haben.
Aber er ist einfach anders.
Viele können nicht abwarten,
bis es endlich losgeht
und finden, das sei alles unnötig.
Aber das ist der wichtigste Punkt
beim Tätowieren: das Motiv.
Wenn das nicht sitzt ...
Auch das am schönsten gestochene
Tattoo ist nicht cool,
wenn es schief
oder falsch platziert ist.
* Spannungsvolle Musik *
Unsere Haut
besteht aus drei Schichten:
die Oberhaut, die Lederhaut
und die Unterhaut.
Die grosse Kunst des Tätowierens ist,
die richtige Hautschicht zu treffen.
Das ist Millimeterarbeit.
Denn geht die Farbe
nur in die Oberhaut,
verschwindet das Tattoo
bereits nach ein paar Wochen.
Sticht der Tätowierer zu tief,
trifft die Nadel
auf die gut durchblutete Unterhaut.
Neben zusätzlichen Schmerzen
verfliessen die Farben,
und das Bild
hat keine klaren Konturen.
Ein erfahrener Tätowierer sticht
die Nadel 1-2 mm in die Lederhaut.
Dort wird die Farbe von Fresszellen
umschlossen und eingelagert.
Im Lauf der Zeit
wird etwa ein Drittel der Farbe
vom Körper abgebaut.
* Möwenkreischen *
In Brunnen im Kanton Schwyz
befindet sich die Praxis
von Bettina Schlagenhauff.
Die Dermatologin sieht bei
ihrer Arbeit immer wieder Probleme,
die nach einer Tätowierung auftreten.
Die meisten Probleme
treten eigentlich
unmittelbar nach dem Tätowieren auf.
Es kann
zu verzögerter Wundheilung kommen,
Infektionen
direkt durch die Einstiche,
durch Eindringen von Bakterien
oder den Fremdkörpern,
die ja in die Haut gebracht werden.
Das kann zu Brennen,
durchaus auch Schwellungen,
Blasen und Krustenbildung führen,
was in der Regel wieder verheilt,
wenn es gut behandelt wird.
Aber wenn es dumm läuft,
kann es auch Narben geben.
Wenn man sehr viel Farbe in der Haut
hat, v.a. dunkle, schwarze Farben,
und sich damit an die Sonne begibt,
werden die Farben heiss.
Es gibt schreckliche
sog. fototoxische Reaktionen.
Da reagiert die Haut
mit Schwellungen,
Rötungen, und man hat Schmerzen.
Sonnenbäder verändern die Farben.
Sie bringen sie einerseits
schneller zum Verblassen,
andererseits
entstehen wieder Abbauprodukte,
die gefährlich sein oder einfach
Allergien auslösen können.
Vermutlich
sehen wir deswegen in unserer Praxis
immer wieder Leute mit Tattoos,
die noch Monate oder Jahre danach
plötzlich Knotenbildungen
in den Tattoos bekommen.
Und das muss behandelt werden.
Eigentlich soll ja
der Tätowierer keine Fehler machen.
Meinem Mitarbeiter passierte
aber doch ein Missgeschick,
als er mir diesen Stern
hier tätowierte.
Er machte zuerst
die oberen Zacken richtig,
dann begann er
auf der anderen Seite
und verwechselte dabei
eben die Seiten.
Dann war es
nicht mehr zu reparieren.
Heute würde Herbert Hoffmann
vielleicht in
eine Tattoo-Entfernungspraxis gehen.
Geschäftsführer Peter Steiner
behandelt Michel Faude,
der bereits zur vierten
Laserbehandlung in die Praxis kommt.
Schauen wir mal am Computer,
wie das aussieht.
Das hier ist vom letzten Mal.
Genau, sehr gut.
Ein grosser Teil wurde entfernt.
Und man darf auch nie vergessen,
wie es zu Beginn aussah:
und zwar so.
Man sieht einen schönen Ablauf:
So ist es heute,
so nach letztem Mal,
so nach der Behandlung davor
und so war es zu Beginn.
Genial.
- Der Verlauf ist sehr gut.
Ich bin wirklich sehr zufrieden.
Es sieht alles gut aus, ich
untersuche die Haut noch genauer.
Dann können wir
mit der Behandlung starten.
Ja, sehr gerne.
- Okay.
Das Tattoo
wird mit jeder Behandlung schwächer.
Ob es ganz verschwindet,
hängt auch von der Farbe ab.
Ein Tattoo
lässt man v.a. dann entfernen,
wenn der Grund, wieso man es stechen
liess, seine Gültigkeit verliert.
Entweder findet die Identifikation
mit der Bedeutung nicht mehr statt
oder wird sogar zur Last,
oder man findet es
ästhetisch nicht mehr schön.
Das ist bei mir der Fall:
Ich finde es nicht mehr schön.
Okay, wir starten.
- Mhm.
Ich kühle zuerst deine Haut ab.
Wenn sie genug kühl ist,
starte ich mit dem Lasern.
Wenn du während des Lasern
eine Pause brauchst, sagst du es,
dann stoppen wir,
ansonsten mache ich einfach weiter.
Ist das gut?
- Gut.
Laserentfernungen
macht man schon seit 20 Jahren.
Wenn man früher Tattoos überhaupt
entfernen konnte,
versuchte man, sie abzuschaben -
ganz einfach.
Man versuchte,
sie herauszuschneiden,
was man auch heute noch
mit einer Operation machen kann.
Man macht eine Exzision
und schneidet sie heraus.
Es gibt die sog. Water injection,
bei der
die Farbe herausgespült wird.
Es gibt auch eine Variante
mit chemischem Peeling,
dabei wird mit Säure gearbeitet.
Diese Säure
wird unter die Haut eingebrannt,
um dort
eine chemische Reaktion zu erzeugen,
damit das Tattoo verschwindet.
Diese Methode
ist immer mit Narben verbunden.
Die Laserentfernung ist definitiv
die sanfteste Methode,
um ein Tattoo zu entfernen.
Hat es jeweils mehr geschmerzt,
oder schmerzt es etwa gleich stark?
Es geht.
- Es geht?
Vom Empfinden her
etwa ähnlich wie letztes Mal.
Ähnlich wie letztes Mal.
Das Ziel beim Lasern ist,
die Farbe zu zertrümmern
oder zu verkleinern,
damit unser Körper imstande ist,
mit gewissen Zellen diese zer-
kleinerte Farbe abzutransportieren.
Schwarze Tattoos lassen sich
grundsätzlich am besten behandeln.
Je heller die Farbe wird, desto
schwieriger wird die Behandlung.
Gelb z.B.
ist sehr schwierig zu behandeln,
auch Orange kann schwierig sein.
Weiss ist ein grosses Problem
für uns.
Gut, das sieht gut aus.
Ich würde es als Mischung zwischen
Stechen und Schneiden bezeichnen.
Es entsteht Wärme,
aber man empfindet ein Stechen,
und weil das Lasergerät über
die Haut fährt, auch ein Schneiden.
Ich lasse dieses Tattoo
und eines am Rücken entfernen.
Das machen wir
in Doppelbehandlungen.
Grundsätzlich
muss sich der Kunde bewusst sein,
dass eine Tattoo-Entfernung
meistens ein Vielfaches kostet
als das Tattoo selber.
Im Gegensatz zum Tattoo-Stechen
dauert die Entfernung
Monate bis Jahre.
* Asiatisch anmutende Musik *
Ein samoanischer Tätowierer
braucht beim traditionellen Klopfen
Assistenten,
welche die Haut richtig spannen.
Eine Aufgabe, die viel Finger-
spitzengefühl und Erfahrung braucht.
Du bewegst dich nicht mit,
wenn ich mich bewege. - Ja, okay.
Wischen.
Im Normalfall
braucht es drei Schläge.
Der erste Schlag öffnet,
der zweite bringt das Pigment ein
und der dritte setzt es
an den Platz, normalerweise.
Aber das kann man
nicht generell sagen,
weil die Haut
immer anders reagiert.
Jeder hat ein anderes Werkzeug,
einen anderen Rhythmus.
Ich habe auch verschiedene Stöcke,
mit denen ich
in einem anderen Rhythmus schlage.
Es kommt auch aufs Werkzeug an.
Es ist je nach Künstler individuell
und kommt auch aufs Design an.
Erst wenn man die Techniken kennt,
weiss man, was man tut.
Dann weisst du noch lange nicht,
was du tust,
bis du deinen eigenen Stil hast.
Das ist das Schlimme:
Nach zehn Jahren, weiss man mal
ein bisschen, was los ist.
Lache nicht, da vorne.
So.
Es ist auch wichtig,
was man den Lehrlingen sagt.
Viele wollen das nicht lernen,
weil sie denken,
es sei ein Sklavenjob.
Aber das ist der einzige Job,
bei dem man das lernt.
Denn wenn du nicht weisst,
was du ihnen sagen sollst,
wie willst du dann klopfen?
Wichtig ist die Stelle,
wo er gerade klopft
und in welche Richtung er klopft.
Und natürlich
in welcher Geschwindigkeit,
und wie gespannt er die Haut
gerade gebraucht.
Mal ist es weniger, mal mehr.
Man muss dafür
natürlich das Gefühl haben,
das ist schon etwas schwierig.
Es ist ganz anders,
als mit der Maschine zu tätowieren,
es ist sehr traditionell.
Da er Leute dafür brauchte,
bot ich ihm an, das zu lernen.
Wenn mir Tomasi
das irgendwann erlaubt.
Wenn sie das Tätowieren
als normale Arbeit ausführen wird,
dann weiss sie mehr als die meisten.
Aber eine Frau an diesen Instru-
menten ist normalerweise ein Tabu
in Samoa,
in der samoanischen Kultur.
Dementsprechend richte ich mich
nach den Regeln der Familie.
Da gibt es halt
recht wenig Verständnis,
auch was westliche Europäer
im Tätowierbereich anbelangt,
die diese Arbeit
als Dienstleistung machen.
Wenn sie von jemandem wie mir hören,
denken sie,
ich hätte ja
nicht alle Tassen im Schrank.
Aber es darf sich jeder selbst
von der Wahrheit überzeugen
und hinfliegen.
Dann sehen wir, was Sache ist.
Bei mir hat man es noch
relativ bequem, sage ich mal.
So, ja.
Sie kann jetzt spannen und mit
der Hand helfen, unten zu spannen.
Bleib unten.
- Mhm.
Nein, unten bleiben hier.
- Ja.
Drücke auf deine Hand hier,
die bleibt.
Nicht drehen.
Und du:
Daumen runter, Daumen runter.
Diese Methode ist bedeutend
angenehmer - nur schon akustisch -
als das Geräusch der Maschine.
Man kann sich besser
darauf vorbereiten.
Man hört das Klopfen und weiss,
jetzt kommen die Nadeln.
Die ganze psychische Vorbereitung
für jedes Einstechen der Nadeln
ist viel einfacher.
* Sphärische Elektromusik *
Es ist spannend zu sehen,
was es alles hat.
Die ganze Kreativität
und Individualität hier
ist sehr eindrücklich.
Egal, wo man hinschaut,
man sieht etwas Neues.
Das ist extrem spannend.
* Piepen von R2-D2 *
Die Fantasy Basel ist für einen
Cartoon- und Fantasy-Fan wie Dominic
ein Paradies
und eine wichtige Inspirationsquelle.
Zudem hat er einen weiteren Termin
bei seinem Haustätowierer.
Es gibt einiges zu tun,
denn er möchte vorwärtsmachen,
solange die Pigmentfarben
in der Schweiz noch erlaubt sind.
Okay, ich glaube, ich habe alles.
Du darfst dich hinlegen.
* Gemächliche Musik *
Meine Tattoos zeigen, was mich
auszeichnet und was ich erlebt habe.
Das liess ich
auf meine Haut stechen,
um es in Erinnerung zu behalten,
und um gewisse Dinge
nicht zweimal durchleben zu müssen.
Ich habe viele Totenköpfe,
Joker, eine Kette ...
Was bedeuten sie?
- Sie haben keine Bedeutung.
Ich mache Tattoos,
weil sie mir gefallen.
Das ist mein Schmetterling
mit Namen und Geburtsdatum
meines zweiten Sohnes.
Der Phönix bedeutet für mich
Freiheit, er ersteht aus der Asche.
Ich wurde ziemlich oft gehänselt.
Dass ich endlich mal mein Leben
leben kann, nicht so,
wie es die anderen wollen -
das bedeutet der Phönix für mich.
Was bedeutet es?
Es ist bloss eine Fledermaus,
ich mag Fledermäuse.
Eine Bedeutung
hat es eigentlich nicht.
Ich sah es im Internet, fand es cool
und wollte auch so eines.
Findest du, Tattoos sind zu teuer?
Nein, denn es ist ein Kunstwerk.
Ob ein Kunstwerk an der Wand oder
auf dem Körper ist - es ist Kunst.
Viele bezahlen 10'000 Fr.
für ein Kunstwerk an der Wand.
Da bezahle ich gerne viel Geld,
um ein Kunstwerk auf mir zu haben.
So habe ich es immer dabei
und kann es zeigen.
Ich finde es eine tolle Sache.
* Asiatisch anmutende Musik *
* Sie streiten sich unverständlich. *
Du bist so eine Diva.
Langsam
endet auch Andi Stieglers Tortur.
So, wir gehen in Richtung Finale.
Kurz vor Schluss nach 2 Std.
hat man es langsam gesehen.
Man spürt es mehr,
alles ist empfindlicher.
So empfindlich,
dass auch das Wegwischen
von Farbe und Blut schmerzhaft ist.
Es fühlt sich an wie Muskelkater,
und jemand würde draufdrücken.
Nach diesen 2 Std. bin ich froh,
es geschafft zu haben.
So.
Fertig, wir können
den Rest fertig machen.
Perfekt.
Andi, du hast es geschafft
für heute. - Ja.
Das ist ein Diamant,
der im Haus steckt.
Er wächst gemeinsam
mit deinem Haus,
deiner Frau,
deinen Kindern, den Regeln
und dem Prozess
des Gebens und Nehmens.
Alle wohnen in einem Haus
zusammen als Einheit,
das von Aussen beschützt ist.
Es ist wirklich sensationell.
Die Erwartungen sind übertroffen.
Auch wenn es vorgezeichnet wird,
weiss man nicht,
wie das Endresultat aussehen wird.
Mit den Mustern und den Strukturen
ist es am Schluss noch mal anders,
die feine Arbeit, die feinen Linien.
Ich weiss,
wieso ich Tomasi vertrauen kann.
Voilà.
Fabe kann zurzeit noch aus einer
grossen Pigmentvielfalt schöpfen.
Dass das bald
nicht mehr möglich sein soll,
versteht er nicht.
Würste oder andere Dinge,
die wir grillieren und verkohlen,
sind hochgradig krebserregend.
Da müsste man sich auch fragen,
wieso der Bund
das Grillen nicht verbietet.
Ich glaube, wenn es
zum alltäglichen Leben gehört
und ein Teil von uns ist,
dann ist es okay.
Wie der Gesetzgeber die
gesundheitlichen Risiken einschätzt,
wird die Zukunft zeigen.
So viele Termine wie dieses Jahr
hatte ich noch nie.
Kaum war ein Tattoo verheilt,
kam bereits das nächste.
Das zehrt mit der Zeit an einem,
denn es nicht sehr angenehm,
unter permanenten Schmerzen zu sein.
Deshalb mache ich
gerne wieder mal eine Pause.
Tschüss. - Vielen Dank.
- Danke, dass du vorbeikamst.
Wir sehen uns im Studio wieder.
Du meldest dich per Telefon?
Gutes Verheilen, tschüss.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Nina Oeggerli - 2023